the universe survival Arc what's
important to understand here is that
Sumit Tomo earned his music degree in
the states studying at the prestigious
Berkeley music College this man has been
a spectacular solo saxophonist for much
of his career and boy did he ever put
that to use in this Arc that big
orchestral sound from the black Arc was
now combined with an incredible Jazz
influence flare achieving something that
I think often goes underlooked he
created an unmistakably unique sound I
think that's why this Arc music sits so
fondly in the fandom's minds too Yamoto
tokunaga as far as Japanese composers go
I don't think anyone since kakuchi has
managed to create something so
recognizable these Works weren't just
your average anime score these
distinctly inseparably were Dragon Ball
[Music]
super